la soeur du shah d'iran la presse
achraf échappe à un attentat sur la côte
d'azur deuxième vol libre de la navette
spatiale américaine en exclusivité les
images de l'intérieur de la navette
nouvel entretien guirec jce cave ils ont
abordé les relations économiques franco
polonaise le diagnostic des experts sur
l'économie française ce soir laurent
fabius du parti socialiste mais à
messieurs bonsoir
il est près de 4 heures du matin une
rolls royce le long de la plage à
antibes une image classique de la côte
d'azur pour un certain nombre de gens un
certain monde ce qui se couchent tard à
l'intérieur la princesse achraf la soeur
jumelle du shah d'iran
à ses côtés sa dame de compagnie
habituellement les deux femmes occupent
une place différente à l'arrière de la
voiture soudain la rolls et criblé de
balles qui se dirigent tout vers la
place que devait occuper la princesse la
princesse est indemne mais sa compagne
moeurs immédiatement voici brièvement
résumé le nouvel attentat qui mobilise
plusieurs polices sur la côte d'azur
sans qu'il soit encore possible ce soir
de dire avec certitude si le mobile est
politique ou de simple vengeance soirée
sanglant de soirée banale le gotha
connaît bien la route qui va du palm
beach de cannes à golfe-juan pourtant
pourtant les impacts de balles qui
marque la chaussée témoignent que la
nuit dernière on a voulu tuer et
seulement 3 heures 45 une 504 bleus avec
trois hommes à bord coince la rolls de
la princesse ashra et coups de feu
claquent bat veulent pas de discussions
juste des balle de 11 43 et 1 vers 3h30
du matin au moins cinq ou six coups de
feu
j'ai regardé par la fenêtre j'ai vu une
voiture qui démarrait j'ai regardé à
gauche à droite voir s'il ya le par
quelqu'un de blessé sur la route qu
absolument rien vu une mesure touchant
miraculeusement indemne de la princesse
ashra a pu regagner sa villa de golf
drouot les policiers l'interrogent
l'attentât fait pourtant une victime une
amie de la princesse qui avaient pris
place à l'arrière de la rolls ce qui a
peut-être trompé les agresseurs
le chauffeur a été légèrement blessé
quant au quatrième passage et il est
également sains et saufs pour les
policiers ne fait pas de doute que le
mobile de cet attentat est
essentiellement politique
l'hypothèse d'un règlement de compte
n'est pas totalement exclu en tout cas
elle ne retient pas pour l'instant
l'attention des enquêteurs
surnommé la panthère noire la princesse
achraf sur ces images en 1971 avec
monsieur ou tante a joué pendant de
nombreuses années un rôle important dans
la politique de son pays très écouté du
chat d'un caractère autoritaire elle
remplit de nombreuses missions
internationales aux moments difficiles
de la couronne impériale notamment
auprès de staline elle participe en 1953
à la contre révolution qui permis le
retour du chat sur le trône en plus de
ses activités politiques
ses détracteurs l'accusent d'avoir des
contacts dans les milieux internationaux
du trafic de la drogue considérée comme
l'une des adeptes de la tendance dure
son rôle politique semble avoir diminué
depuis quelques années aussi peut-on se
demander si la thèse de l'attentât
politique soit la seule à retenir dans
quatre ou cinq heures les européens vont
lancer pour la première fois un
satellite d'application c'est à dire un
satellite qui ne soit pas uniquement
expérimental comme les neuf autres
lancée par le club européen depuis dix
ans celui cette nuit s'appelle l'hôte et
s il va s'occuper de télécommunications
mais comment l'état actuel des choses
les européens n'ont toujours pas de base
de lancement et bien satellite partira
cette nuit de cap canaveral aux états
unis au ts filmé ici au cours des essais
à toulouse et donc un satellite chargé
d'acheminer des conversations
téléphoniques ou des émissions de
télévision
mais comme ses prédécesseurs au ts
construit en france par matra ne peut
pas gagner de l'argent il se heurte au
monopole de la société intel sat société
internationale de télécommunication à
domination américaine la règle est
simple tout satellite lancé avec une
fusée américaine et c'est le cas de thé
est ne peut pas combattre le monopole
d'intelsat donc au ts fera des essais de
télécommunications pour l'europe mais
l'avenir dans ce domaine est très riche
de promesses
voici un document canadien montrant
comment le simple téléspectateur peut
recevoir directement chez lui
les émissions d'un satellite quel qu'il
soit voyez que le premier qui disposera
de cette technique pourra envoyer ses
émissions dans le monde entier
cela devient un instrument de propagande
fantastique sans compter les
innombrables bénéfices publicitaires
l'europe a déjà son projet il s'appelle
h sat
mais pour cela il nous faudra aussi
notre propre fusée
ce sera ariane elle sera prête en 1981
deuxième volet d'une actualité spatiale
assez fourni le second vol libre tout à
l'heure de la navette spatiale endeavour
ait un premier vol de cinq minutes au
dessus de la californie vol réussi et
qui va nous permettre pour la première
fois de vous montrer des images de
l'intérieur de la navette comme si vous
y étiez vue de la queue du boeing porter
voici la séparation nous sommes à 7300 m
ce deuxième vol libre voix de joan gold
victory aux commandes de la navette pour
un petit tour de cinq minutes
mais cette fois ci les virages à
effectuer sont beaucoup plus compliqués
au cours de la descente des astronautes
que vous voyez ici grâce à une caméra
placée à l'intérieur de la cabine de
pilotage doivent étudier les manoeuvres
possible de la navette au dessus du
désert californien celle ci pèse 68
tonnes et n'a pas de moteur donc chaque
manoeuvre est fait en planant les
virages les piquer les cabré malgré cela
la navette s'est parfaitement comportée
au cours de ce vol et en est
actuellement à l'étude de l'atterrissage
au retour du cosmos en 79 elle décollera
comme une fusée volera comme un
satellite et se posera comme un avion
rappelons que c'est elle qui emportera
le premier français dans l'espace vers
1980 premier à col accord salarial
pardon accord salarial de l'année
conclut ce matin à la ratp tous les
syndicats modérés ont signé la cgt et la
cfdt ne l'ont pas fait un accord qui
prévoit une progression du pouvoir
d'achat de 1,1 pour cent dans la
meilleure des hypothèses deuxième
journée de la visite en france du
premier polonais edward gierek un
mélange du protocole et d'entretiens
politiques avec au passage une halte à
deux monuments que les chefs d'état
étrangers commencent à bien connaître
l'arc de triomphe et l'hôtel de ville ce
qui par parenthèse aura permis à
monsieur guirec de revoir jacques chirac
déjà invité hier à l'élysée pour dîner
l'occasion pour les photographes et les
cameramen d'immortaliser une poignée de
main avec le président la république
une poignée de main remarquée en effet
au cours du dîner de gala offert hier
soir à l'elysée en l'honneur d'edward
gierek et auquel assistaient plus d'un
millier de personnes
le numéro un polonais devait revoir
jacques chirac ce matin à l'hôtel de
ville visite traditionnelle chez le
maire de paris où edward gierek a été
reçu avec tous les honneurs réservés à
un chef d'état en tant que secrétaire du
parti ouvrier polonais c'est bien lui en
effet qui dirige la pologne avant d'être
l'hôte à déjeuner de raymond barre
edward gierek avait déposé une gerbe de
fleurs l'arc de triomphe et saluer les
anciens combattants occasion pour lui de
rappeler le mot d'ordre des polonais
pour votre liberté et pour la nôtre et
puis ce soir deuxième entretien en tête
à tête avec valéry giscard d'estaing le
numéro un polonais le chef de l'état on
parlait des pointes conflits dans le
monde mais surtout des nouveaux accords
économiques franco polonais qui seront
signés demain après-midi avant le départ
d'edward gierek sur le fond maintenant
des conversations franco-polonaise un
leit motiv développer davantage les
relations économiques et commerciales
raymond barre a annoncé aujourd'hui que
de larges accords de coopération seront
signés au terme de cette visite
jusqu alors en effet le volume des
échanges entre les deux pays n'étaient
vraiment pas à la hauteur de la
générosité des intentions politiques
la france et la pologne sont de vieux
partenaire et c'est depuis cinq ans que
les échanges entre les deux pays ont
vraiment décollé puisqu'ils ont été
multipliées par cinq entre 1972 et 1976
des échanges al'avantage de paris qui
deuxième fournisseur occidentale de la
pologne vend plus à ce pays qui ne lui
achète précisément cachetons nous à la
pologne
eh bien d'abord et surtout des matières
premières matières premières
industrielles comme le charbon
la france en a acheté pour plus d'un
milliard de francs en 1976 comme le
cuivre aussi dans la pologne est le
neuvième producteur au monde
la france en a commandé 30 mille tonnes
est allé sur quatre années
outre l'exploitation de la pologne les
produits agricoles rappelez-vous des
pommes de terre polonaise lors de la
pénurie de l'année passée la pologne
vont aussi des chevaux à la france
ces derniers temps le gouvernement de
monsieur guirec soucieux de diversifier
des exportations a également entrepris
de vendre à la france des produits finis
notamment du matériel agricole et des
bateaux la france de son côté fournit
essentiellement des biens d'équipement
la pologne elle en est même le
fournisseur numéro un parmi les pays
occidentaux à l'actif de l'industrie
française quelques grandes réalisations
telles que l' usine chimique construite
par creusot loire à police ou encore
l'installation avec la rfa de deux
laminoirs dans le gigantesque complète
de katowice pourtant la conjoncture
mondiale et la crise économique que
traverse la pologne incite aujourd'hui
le gouvernement polonais à ralentir ses
achats à l'étranger
l'industrie française en subit le
contrecoup et au premier semestre 77 nos
exportations en direction de la pologne
ont très largement diminué deux grands
rendez vous politiques demain la
signature commune du manifeste électoral
de la majorité mais là pas vraiment de
surprise à attendre
seul petit accroc le déjeuner prévu
entre jean pierre soisson et jacques
chirac est reporté en revanche tout est
possible de l'autre côté de la place du
palais bourbon je veux dire chez les
socialistes qui accueilleront demain les
30 négociateur au sommet de
l'actualisation du programme commun pour
la circonstance
le ps a même créé à battre deux cloisons
pour permettre aux participants de
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
alors sur quels dossiers pour harmoniser
quelle position qu'elle divergences
c'est ce que nous allons voir avec
patricia charnel alors il ya plusieurs
chapitres que les partis de gauche
devront traiter demain est le premier
grand chapitre des désaccords c'est la
politique sociale d'abord le smic le
parti communiste revendiquent
l'augmentation du smic à 2200 francs dès
aujourd'hui ce qui le porterait compte
tenu de la hausse des prix à 2400 francs
environ après les élections pour ne pas
pour le parti socialiste en revanche le
smic doit être au minimum de 2200 francs
mais après les élections alors deuxième
point maintenant l'éventail des salaires
oui alors le parti communiste souhaite
un écart hiérarchique de 1 à 5
au terme de la législature le ps comme
les radicaux et donc beaucoup plus
réservés le parti socialiste est
favorable à une réduction de l'éventail
de salaire qui pourrait se situer entre
1 7 où 1 9
michel rocard l'a dit récemment mais et
c'est très important
c'est dur
herman des salaires doit porter non pas
tant sur les salaires eux mêmes que sur
l'éventail des revenus alors deuxième
grande divergence maintenant les
nationales pour le parti communiste
il faut ajouter aux neuf nationalisation
prévu dans le texte de 1972 la
sidérurgie la compagnie française des
pétroles et peugeot citroën les
communistes vous le savez demande
également la nationalisation des
entreprises dont l'état procéderait
environ 50% des parts en revanche le
parti socialiste et les radicaux de
gauche sont plus réservés ils veulent
tous les deux s'en tenir aux textes de
1972 c'est à dire aux neuf
nationalisation prévu le ps toutefois
propose une transformation des prêts de
l'état à la sidérurgie par exemple en
prise de participation majoritaire
enfin et c'est intéressant les radicaux
de gauche réclament toujours la
suppression d'une petite phrase du texte
de 1972 stipulant que les travailleurs
d'une entreprise pouvez en demander la
nationalisation alors maintenant
troisième grand thème de désaccord nous
avons essayé de résumer la défense
nationale oui alors là c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que les trois
parties les radicaux les communistes et
les socialistes sont d'accord sur deux
points le désarmement n'est le
désarmement général qu'il souhaite tous
les trois et ils veulent aussi le
maintien en état de l'armement nucléaire
mais alors les divergences sont très
nombreuses pour nous résumer je vous
inviterai seulement 2 le les communistes
préconise une défense tous azimuts cela
mitterrand françois mitterrand l'a
refusée très énergiquement
en revanche la proposition socialiste
d'un référendum sur la force de frappe
est encore aujourd'hui sèchement refusé
par les communes merci alors voilà donc
pour le catalogue des divergences il y
en a d'autres puisque le parti
communiste les chiffrer à 70 alors au
delà peut-être plus important dans les
copains les intentions des uns et les
autres une fois que finalement ce dans
une négociation de cette nature ce qui
compte ce sont moins les catalogues de
divergences et éventuellement les points
d'accord que les intentions profondes
rappelez vous la situation en 1972 je
crois qu'on peut dire qu'à cette époque
le parti communiste et le parti
socialiste rencontré des difficultés au
moins aussi importante que celle qu'ils
rencontrent aujourd'hui et ils ont
réussi à se mettre d'accord à partir du
moment où ils avaient la volonté l'un et
l'autre d'aboutir
alors aujourd'hui précisément on se pose
la question et les partenaires se pose
même la question chacun affirme qu'il a
cette volonté d'aboutir mais met en
doute en tout cas s'interroge
sur la volonté d'aboutir de son
partenaire et demain quand chacun va
s'asseoir à la table
eh bien chacun s'interrogera sur
l'intention profonde de son visage d'un
pronostic d'oeil ça va être long et bien
c'est difficile de faire un pronostic je
répondrais peut-être par une boutade si
ses courses et que ça a mal marché et
c'est que ce sera sans doute la rupture
mais vrai dire je crois que ce soir
personne n'y croit vraiment alors ce
sera plutôt long combien de temps le
parti communiste lui ne donne aucun
chiffre et aucune date le temps ne fait
rien à l'affairé ce qui compte pour lui
c'est une bonne actualisation d'un bon
programme tandis que pour le parti
socialiste le parti socialiste lui admet
qu'il faudra sans doute une deuxième
réunion au sommet préparé par d'autres
contacts mais il ne voudrait pas se
laisser entraîner dans une série de
sommets
merci avec nous ce soir laurent fabius
membre du comité directeur du parti
socialiste mais ce n'est pas l'un des
négociateurs de demain pour
l'actualisation du programme commun
c'est d'ailleurs pas pour ça que nous
avons invité depuis hier vous le savez
pendant toute la semaine
nous essayons de radioscopie l'économie
française alors un diagnostic et des
remèdes d'abord un diagnostic est ce que
là la france est malade est ce que
l'économie française est mal et pourquoi
oui je crois que l'économie française
est malade et que lorsqu'on essaie de
porter un diagnostic ses échecs partout
pour expliquer cet échec
la majorité elle se réfugie derrière un
certain nombre de raisons et surtout
derrière la hausse du prix du pétrole
nous nous pensons qu'il s'agit de
quelque chose de beaucoup plus profond
et que c'est en fait le système
capitaliste dans son ensemble qui est en
crise alors il ya un petit peu de voir
maintenant vous remets de imaginons que
la gauche revienne au pouvoir en mars
vous préconisez l'augmentation des
salaires l'augmentation des salaires
tout le monde sait que ça veut dire
aussi l'inflation
comment est ce que vous vous y prendre
pour éviter là une autre
c'est vrai que là il ya une différence
de conception totale entre la droite et
la gauche que pour la droite
les salaires sont responsables de
l'inflation pour nous les salaires même
s'ils peuvent être une cause de hausse
de prix c'est surtout une nécessité
sociale de les augmenter
et une façon de relancer l'économie
alors si comme nous proposons
les bas salaires sont augmentés ça
permettra aux salariés de consommer
davantage et donc à l'ensemble des
entreprises de travailler à pleine
capacité et donc finalement de créer de
l'emploi sans impression en maintenant
votre approche du prêtre de l'employé e
bernard qui gagne elle nous disait que
en cas de victoire de la gauche
finalement le chômage de 10 millions a
guère à peu près une somme ridicule en
deux cent mille vols soit qu'il était
optimiste en ce qui concerne les
prévisions de la majorité je compte le
chômage pas beaucoup augmenté si la
majorité par malheur rester au pouvoir
mais si la gauche remporte ils ne
diminuent en communauté pessimiste si
mon avis ils étaient pessimistes
là aussi il ya univers alda proches
total pour les le cas de la durée du
travail la durée du travail
on a une situation absurde elle est
excessive en moyenne et par ailleurs
vous avez un million deux cent mille
chômeurs nous nous disons il faut mieux
répartir la durée du travail et d'où nos
propositions
la baisse de la retraite 60 ans et 55
ans pour les femmes et aller vers les 35
heures ou presque d'un coup de baguette
magique parce que la gauche est au
pouvoir le chômage va diminuer
y a pas de baguette magique je crois que
on ne peut pas dire tout est possible
tout de suite mais l'essentiel est
possible est ce que votre approche
générale des premiers conomique est très
différente de celle du parti communiste
nous verrons d'ailleurs après demain
avec la liste communiste non l' approche
d'ensemble n'est pas très différente en
ce qui concerne par exemple la nécessité
de la relance de la consommation des
nationalisations de la planification
mais ce qui nous oppose peut-être c'est
que nous pensons nous que les français
le comprennent
tout n'est pas possible tout de suite si
vous voulez notre règle nous ne
promettons que ce que nous pouvons tenir
mais nous tiendrons tous que nous
promettons c'est une pierre lancée dans
le jardin communiste non c'est la
définition de la position socialiste
jaume à ce deuxième volet maintenant de
notre aide aussi économique la santé de
nos voisins hier c'était les etats-unis
aujourd'hui l'italie à travers un
exemple particulier celui de la crise de
l'industrie textile
une usine de produits textiles à une
trentaine de kilomètres au sud de rome
elle est fermée depuis une semaine c'est
la faillite il ya actuellement des
dizaines d' usine qui sont obligées de
fermer leurs portes en italie surtout
dans le secteur textile
c'est une image de la crise économique
les chefs d'entreprise explique qu'il
n'y a plus de marché mais aussi que les
syndics ont présenté des revendications
qui ont fait augmenter de manière
exorbitante les coûts de production les
marchés italiens et les marchés
mandina's pas il m'a seulement les
marchés américains nous entendre et de
travail pour le marché américain
seulement on n'a pas la possibilité des
livres est allé à délivrer juste pour
tenir les clientes
c'est à dire les clients qui doit voir
très confiants mais nous pour la
marchandise à la libération prij imaginé
ce serait trop facile de rejeter la
responsabilité de la crise sur les
syndicats c'est un manque d'imagination
voici une autre usine de produits
textiles mais qui elle fonctionne
peut-être pas dans l'euphorie mais
normalement ici les syndicats ont essayé
de trouver un terrain d'entente avec le
patronat afin que la production continue
en ce moment il ne s'agit pas de
demander des augmentations de salaires
mais de conserver son emploi
je dirais même de collaborer puisque le
secteur textile est en crise comment se
fait-il que dans un même secteur
industriel le textile il y à des
entreprises qui se déclare en faillite
et d'autres qui ont réussi à surmonter
la crise
car en italie s'il est vrai qu'il y à un
million sept cent mille chômeurs et que
la production industrielle a connu une
croissance voisine de zéro
il veut aussi qu'il ya des entreprises
qui se sont complètement transformé pour
ne pas disparaître
la concurrence dans le secteur du
textile vient des pays sous développés
alors l'important c'est de savoir ce que
ces pays peuvent offrir et ceux qui ne
peuvent pas offrir
évidemment dans les pays sous-développés
la main d'oeuvre ne coûte rien mais nous
nous avons la technologie nous avons si
l'imagination et le sens de
l'organisation
il y un an
il y avait en italie une inflation de
23%
maintenant on en est à 18 % c'est un
progrès dans certaines industries
l'absentéisme est passé de 25 à 10 %
c'est donc qu'il est possible
d'améliorer la situation en italie la
reprise économique n'est pas pour demain
mais il n'est pas impossible
norvege majorité non socialiste au
parlement mais il semble que le premier
ministre actuel puisse continuer à
présider un gouvernement minoritaire la
situation politique n'a donc pas du tout
été clarifiée par ces élections
karl iband le l'ancien numéro deux du
zaïre condamné aujourd'hui à mort
l'ancien homme de confiance du général
mobutu était accusé de haute trahison à
faire ch layer 7 jours après
l'enlèvement du président du patronat
aux allemands un dialogue se poursuit
peut-être entre ravisseurs et autorités
mais nous ne sommes pas tenus au courant
bonne ayant décidé le black out sur
cette affaire il ya une heure valéry
giscard d'estaing a téléphoné au
chancelier schmidt pour lui dire que le
gouvernement français partager l'émotion
du gouvernement fédéral devant les
actions terroristes réprouvée par
l'ensemble de l'opinion
là je cite à peine sorti de prison
hector aristide attaque et il attaque
tous azimuts il attaque pêle-mêle la
firme fiat la cia et surtout le
ministère de l'intérieur
hector aristide bien que libre reste
inculpé accusé de complicité dans le
rapt de monsieur reveni baume pour moi
c'est une persécution politique
elle se terre le montage qui ne tiennent
pas et qui n'a pas tenu
vous pensez que c'est grâce à des
positions monsieur béliveau mon cousin
vite libéré non je suis désolé parce que
je suis innocent j'ai toujours inculpé
au parce que ça c'est là
mettez la main scandent assure malivert
pape allemand fort commentaire du
mystère intérieur accusations stupide et
aberrante
en france le policier et le judiciaire
sont indépendants et avec l'autre de
nouvelles de dernière minute
oui en effet d'abord cette dépêche en
provenance de new delhi en inde l'ancien
premier ministre à la mini raz gandhi
pourrait être arrêté le ministre de
l'intérieur le ministre actuel
l'intérieur a déclaré qu'il détenait la
preuve qui pourrait conduire à
l'arrestation de madame gandhi il
s'agirait une affaire de corruption
et puis cette autre dépêche le chef
d'orchestre léopold stokowski est mort
aujourd'hui en grande bretagne il avait
95 ans demain la prérentrée la rentrée
les adultes c'est devenu une habitude
depuis sept ans le personnel
d'encadrement
entre un jour ou deux avant les élèves
pour régler les derniers problèmes
matériels mais pour 11 millions
d'enfants qui vont entamer l'an 1 de la
réforme haby ce n'est qu'un sursis de
quelques heures quelques heures
mélancolique dont martine laroche
joubert n'a pas eu beaucoup de mal à
souvenirs pour elle c'était il n'ya pas
filante
la chanson du départ en vacances les
cahiers au feu et les mettre aux olives
yeux et bien l'oublier
aujourd'hui ce sont les faits qui brûle
dans les cours de récréation feuilles
des tilleuls il marronniers dont la tête
autre annonce plus sûrement la rentrée
des classes que les avis affichés sur la
porte des écoles le 15 septembre
il va falloir se pencher sur d'autres
feuilles à petits carreaux le dernier
jour des vacances en aligne les chaises
on distribue la craie un dernier coup de
peinture avant le brouhaha de la rentrée
avant le premier appel
le premier asseyez-vous le dortoir pour
les internes
ici ils vont mélanger leurs rêves qu'on
mélange son dentifrice une des multiples
réformes a emporté les héros de conduite
mais les planches on se prépare à être
des armes de bataille homérique ou saft
si les polochon étouffé en finir une
arme de celles qu'on laisse glisser un
14 septembre au soir salle au dessus de
30 me plus que quelques heures et les
mots des vacances perdront leur
signification
viendront des maquis heures de cours
l'histoire ne sera plus celle qu'on se
raconte et met une heure sur l'emploi du
temps physique le sien celui des autres
une nouvelle ère son emploi du temps le
grec
adieu les il a dû l'acropole encore une
heure sous l'emploi du temps
au dernier jour des vacances n'a déjà
plus la saveur des soir d'août la hâte
des derniers achats
l'odeur du plastique le dernier mardi le
dernier d'un temps qui n'a pas encore
d'emplois sur le cahier de texte si je
peux donner un conseil à nos petits amis
c'est celui de lire la nouvelle édition
du petit robert qui vient de sortir en
librairie et qui pour la première fois
depuis sa création il ya dix ans s'est
enrichi de 5000 mots nouveaux
enfin enrichi c'est peut-être un peu
aller loin parce que paraît que
désormais on peut dire par exemple le
brushing de bobonne serait trop un
brushing c'est ça le temps pour terminer
il sera le plus souvent ensoleillé
demain encore cependant quelques ondées
possibles en corse et quelques nuages en
fin de journée dans le nord du pays un
mot de sport pour vous dire que niki
lauda qui a quitté ferrari courra sur
brabham l'année prochaine et pour vous
donner rendez-vous demain à 22h40 pour
la diffusion intégrale en différé du
match de coupe d'europe
nantes prat demain 22h40 pour leur
prochain rendez vous avec la formation
ce soir 23h30 en compagnie d'hervé que
votre bonne soirée à tous à demain